Bodily harm, betrayal, braggadocio. Would it even
be an Iron Man movie without a few particulars?
"From the ashes of captivity,
never has a greater phoenix metaphor
been personified in human history."
Anyone even vaguely familiar with Tony
Stark knows the character suffers from
a massive superiority complex.
Tony is a world-changing genius,
and he is highly aware of that fact. This
leads Tony to believe that he knows better
than anyone else, to the frustration of his
allies and the advantage of his enemies.
That's why a major plot point
in each "Iron Man" movie is
Tony learning humility the hard way. Tony
begins the first film as an arrogant and
selfish weapons manufacturer. It's only
after he is captured by terrorists that
he sees the destruction caused by his
weapons, and vows to stop making them.
In the second movie, Tony has trouble finding a
solution to his deadly illness. Tony undergoes
a reality check, realizing that even his great
intelligence is not enough to rescue him from his
condition. Instead, he has to rely on his father's
help from beyond the grave to find a solution.
In "Iron Man 3", Tony's
trademark arrogance crumbles,
when a mysterious terrorist called the
Mandarin attacks him in his own home in
broad daylight. Tony is forced to concede
he cannot handle this new threat alone and
needs the help of his friends to defeat the
villain, all while keeping a grip on his PTSD.
Female love interests in the MCU too often get
the short end of the stick, but Tony's longtime
love interest, Pepper Potts, bucks this trend by
being an important part of the "Iron Man" films.
Pepper starts out as Tony's assistant,
and the closest thing to a companion
he has in his jet-setting, playboy life.
Throughout the movie, Pepper supports Tony,
even saving his life at one point. In the
second film, Tony and Pepper are officially
a couple. Dealing with his personal illness,
Tony makes Pepper the head of Stark Industries,
and she takes over the entire
organization on Tony's behalf.
But it's in "Iron Man 3" when Tony needs
Pepper the most. Struggling to control
his PTSD following the Battle of New York, Tony
leans hard on Pepper to keep him going through
his insomnia and night terrors. In the end,
Pepper once again personally saves Tony's life
when she also briefly gains superpowers
and helps Tony defeat Aldrich Killian.
When "Iron Man" premiered back in 2008, one major
reason why Tony Stark felt like a breath of fresh
air is that his characterization was so different
from the popular superhero archetypes of the day.
Heroes like Spider-Man and Batman had tortured
inner lives with an unhealthy amount of angst.
Tony is refreshingly free of such a mentality,
and does not usually suffer from a
great deal of self-doubt. In fact,
Tony is so convinced of his own personal
greatness that he routinely makes a point of it.
No moment exemplifies this better than
the end of the first "Iron Man" film.
"I am Iron Man."
In the next film, Tony frames his ownership
of the Iron Man suit as a win for America,
informing a court convened against him:
"I've successfully privatized world
peace. What more do you want?"
Tony Stark is many things. He's a
playboy, a billionaire, a philanthropist,
and a superhero. But before all of that,
Tony is, at his core, an engineer and an
inventor. The entire Iron Man saga begins
because Tony is captured by terrorists,
and the only way to escape is to create a suit
of armor that could get him out of the situation.
The first Iron Man suit was
built in a cave from spare parts,
and it's a very rough affair: big, bulky and
not very fuel-efficient. After returning home,
Tony gets to work creating a
better-designed version of the
suit — which eventually becomes the iconic
red-and-gold armor we all fell in love with.
With each new movie after that,
including the "Avengers" flicks,
Tony debuts new versions of the classic Iron
Man suit. There's the emergency suit hidden
in a briefcase from "Iron Man 2." There's
the army of autonomous suits from "Iron Man
3." There's the Hulkbuster armor from "Avengers:
Age of Ultron" and "Infinity War." And finally,
the nanotech suit that Tony wears in
his battle against Thanos and his army.
The "Iron Man" films are considered the starting
point for the MCU. Not just because they were the
first movies in the franchise to receive
critical acclaim and box office success,
but also because many of the plot points from the
"Iron Man" movies became a staple of the MCU as
a whole. For instance, Tony's quippy nature
has come to be shared by many other heroes,
as has the "the villain has the same power set
as the hero" thing started by Obadiah Stane.
The villain also tends to be someone whom the
hero has scorned in the past. In "Iron Man,"
Tony is so busy working on dismantling his past
as a weapons manufacturer, that he doesn't realize
that his actions are negatively affecting his
company's second-in-command. This leads to the
Number 2 stepping up his efforts to usurp Tony
from the company, attempting to kill Tony in
the process. In "Iron Man 2," Justin Hammer was
a weapons manufacturer who had spent a lifetime
being bested by Tony in their field of work —
a rival looking for an opportunity to one-up
Tony by stealing and improving upon his Iron Man
armor design. To this end, he recruits Ivan Vanko,
aka Whiplash, whose family was previously
crossed by Stark's. Finally, in "Iron Man
3," Aldrich Killian was a researcher whom Tony
had once dismissed and embarrassed. As a result,
Killian builds his own company and dreams
of the day he can finally defeat Tony Stark.
If Pepper Potts is the voice of reason in Tony
Stark's life, and JARVIS is the blindly faithful
ally who will do anything he asks, James "Rhodey"
Rhodes is the happy medium in Tony's inner circle.
Rhodey was Tony's friend long before he became
Iron Man, and he feels a personal obligation
to look out for his reckless comrade — even if it
means breaking the rules or angering Tony himself.
"I'm only gonna say this once. Get out."
As a high-ranking member of the United States Air
Force, Rhodey is often torn between his duty and
his friendship with Tony. In the first "Iron
Man," Rhodey is forced to hide the fact that
it is Tony inside the Iron Man armor getting
into an impromptu dogfight against a couple
of F-22 Raptors. In "Iron Man 2," irked
by Tony's increasingly unstable behavior,
Rhodey is forced to go against his wishes and
confiscate a prototype of the Iron Man armor,
turning it over to the US
Air Force behind his back.
Then in "Iron Man 3," Rhodey has become a
new superhero named Iron Patriot. Once again,
Rhodey is forced to work outside the
law when his suit gets controlled by
the villain to assassinate the president,
as ordered by Alrich Killian. This time,
Rhodey and Tony both work in secret
to bring down the villain's plan.
The world of comic books is roughly divided
into two. Some heroes believe in working within
the law, others believe in working outside of
it. But in the case of Tony Stark, you have a
little bit of both. While Tony's chief priority
is making the world a better, safer place, he
has no interest in doing so by working alongside
the government, at least in the "Iron Man" films.
In the first movie, Tony abruptly shuts down
his weapons manufacturing company that had
been supplying the government with military
arms for decades. He also tries to keep his
identity as Iron Man a secret before once
again abruptly letting the cat out of the
bag. Then "Iron Man 2" deals with the fallout of
Tony's dramatic declaration, as the government
tries to force him to share the tech behind his
armor. Finally, in Iron Man 3, an inside job to
assassinate the President forces Tony and Rhodey
to fly under the radar for the greater good.
Ironically, Tony works with the government
much better in the "Avengers" movies, joining
SHIELD despite his suspicions of their motives.
After causing the events of "Avengers: Age of
Ultron," Tony signs the Sokovia
Accords as a means of atoning for his actions.
When Tony Stark was being cast, the studio
was resistant to the idea of Robert Downey
Jr. playing the role. Director Jon Favreau
fought to cast Downey since he felt that the
actor's very public struggles with his personal
demons would translate very well to Tony Stark,
a character who has historically
struggled with demons of his own.
And so each "Iron Man" movie has an important
side-plot, wherein Tony must learn to confront
his mistakes. In the first movie, Tony finds
out the hard way that the weapons his company
manufacture often wind up in the hands
of terrorists. This prompts him to become
Iron Man and end the destruction his company
had indirectly caused. In the second movie,
Tony's habit of not playing well with
others comes back to bite him, when his
incompetent rival works with the US government
to create new versions of the Iron Man armor.
Finally in "Iron Man 3," Tony's refusal to get
help for his PTSD and his distancing himself
from those seeking to help him lead to severe
and debilitating breakdowns. Tony also gets his
butt handed to him by the villain when he tries to
deal with "the Mandarin" on his own. In the end,
Tony only manages to win after working with
Rhodey and Pepper to bring down Aldrich Killian.
On his own, Tony Stark can be a pretty impossible
character to root for. A self-described "Genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist," Tony
combines extreme intelligence with extreme
arrogance and snark. He can be hard for general
audiences to like, let alone actively support,
especially if we don't get to see Tony in
a vulnerable position from time to time.
"Bit odd… if this was your last birthday party you
were ever gonna have, how would you celebrate it?"
To offset his many, many advantages
in life, every "Iron Man" movie has
a major plot point about Tony struggling with a
life-threatening condition. In the first movie,
Tony gets severely injured in an explosion,
and the only way to keep him alive is through
the miniaturized arc reactor that he invents
and places in his chest. In "Iron Man 2," it
is revealed that the arc reactor has started to
poison his entire body. Once again Tony races
against time to find a cure for his condition
before the poison can shut down his body. In
the final film, Tony suffers from PTSD, which
leaves him a quivering mess and leads him to
make mistakes that almost get him killed. In
this way, each "Iron Man" movie combines Tony's
external struggle against a physical villain
with an internal struggle against his mortality.
While Tony Stark is a very, very smart man,
something he will personally tell you if you let
him, his intelligence does not always translate
to a complete awareness of his surroundings.
This leads to a recurring problem, where Tony does
not realize there is a mole in his trusted circle,
working against his interests. In the first
"Iron Man," the mole is Obadiah Stane,
who is secretly working to steal Tony's inventions
and eventually kill him off. In the second movie,
SHIELD sends Natasha Romanoff, aka Black
Widow, undercover inside Tony's company
to assess his personality, as a prelude to
asking Tony to join the Avengers Initiative.
In "Iron Man 3," Tony has to deal with Maya
Hansen, a former love interest who comes back into
his life with details about a radical new medical
procedure called Extremis. Unbeknownst to Tony,
Maya is secretly working with Aldrich
Killian to turn Extremis into a weapon.
While Maya comes to regret her association
with Killian and tries to help Tony escape,
her actions lead to a great deal of
harm being inflicted upon the world.
Superhero movies generally tend to
keep the villains in the same country
as the hero. Guys like Batman
and Superman fight Americans,
or they fight aliens. But the "Iron
Man" trilogy specifically deals with
foreign terrorists, reflecting on Tony
Stark's past as a weapons manufacturer.
In the first movie, Tony is captured by a
terrorist group in war-torn Afghanistan.
The group makes a return later in the movie,
when they are shown to be working alongside
Obadiah Stane. In the second movie, we get Russian
criminal and international terrorist Ivan Vanko,
aka Whiplash, who nurses a personal grudge
against Tony. Vanko builds his own robot
terrorist army after hijacking the knockoff
Iron Man suits built by Justin Hammer.
Then in "Iron Man 3," Tony has to deal with his
greatest enemy from the comics, the Mandarin.
The film's version of the character is depicted
as the head of a massive international criminal
organization called "The Ten Rings," who have no
problem carrying out attacks on American soil.
Tony finds out this terrorist leader version of
The Mandarin was just an actor set up by Killian.
This version of the Mandarin was later retconned
in "Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings."
Post-credits scenes have become
an expectation for every Marvel
movie. But when the original Iron Man
debuted, the concept of a post-credits
scene was pretty groundbreaking. These
punctuative teasers became staples of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, hinting at
the next expansion or returning character.
"Iron Man" has probably the most iconic
post-credits scene of all time in the MCU.
After many months of speculation, fans
cheered at the end of "Iron Man," when
Samuel L. Jackson steps out of the
shadows as Nick Fury and tells Tony
Stark about the Avengers Initiative. Iron
Man 2's post-credits scene reveals Thor's
hammer sticking out of a crater, signaling
the near-arrival of the God of Thunder.
"Iron Man 3" takes a more easygoing approach,
with Tony Stark having an impromptu
therapy session with Bruce Banner.
"Are you actively napping?"
"I was— I, I, I drifted."
"Where did I lose you?"
After three movies' worth of drama, we'd say Tony
earned the right to take it easy this time around.